mon café
[Musique]
mon café [ __ ]
c'est non
bonsoir
ça va bien ça va c'est un peu long de
café mais c'est cool je me présente je
m'appelle ton village suit le stagiaire
de salut les terriens alors thierry sans
vouloir être chiant je viens d'apprendre
que je suis moins bien payés que les
trois mannequins qui sont au premier
rang
alors ça veut dire qu applaudir s'avoue
plus que d'écrire des blagues c'est ça
le j'ai rien contre vous les filles
parce que c'est vrai que le chauffeur de
salle il demande soit d'applaudir soit
de rigoler et une fois sur deux vous
inversez donc
[Applaudissements]
extraordinaire quand même le monde de la
télévision on arrive à faire croire aux
gens que le samedi soir il ya quatre
mannequins sublime qui s'appelle et qui
disait les filles si on allait voir
salut les terriens sur un banc en bois
pourri pendant deux heures ce
extraordinaire
bilan de la semaine dernière très très
bonnes audiences félicitations thiery un
million deux cent mille téléspectateurs
bravo je peux me permettre ça fait
toujours 65 millions qui chante bat les
couilles un autre débat est d'ailleurs
sur twitter isabelle mergault a marqué
les esprits à semaine dernière ce qui
était en petite nuisette sexy alors je
rappelle juste que là on est dans un
studio avec des lumières il fait chaud
c'est la fête il faut savoir que dehors
c'est la plaine saint denis il ya le
périph le début de l'autoroute 1 si
quelqu'un a des nouvelles isabelle
mergault envoyez nous un message parce
que nous on n'a aucune nouvelle
aujourd'hui les invités ariane brodier
alors rien ne vous dis tout le temps sur
les réseaux sociaux vous cherchez un mec
non j'en cherche plusieurs
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peut-être une idée à la semaine
dernière on savait claude bartolone oui
à une semaine près ton mec qui était
président l'assemblée nationale dames en
plus il nous l'a dit claude bartolone
moi je cherche une blonde bien gaulée au
psg que des tromblons
chris marquès crise et c'est l'un des
jurys de danse avec les stars thiery ou
plutôt le titre ça devrait être dense
avec des mecs que j'ai déjà vu quelque
part mais je me souviens plus d'emplois
et non alors crise il est chorégraphe et
ça c'est génial moi j'ai un excellent
prof de de danse en boîte de nuit c'est
le whisky coca au bout de huit verges à
michael jackson dans ma tête je pense
que je danse mais de l'extérieur on
dirait une crise d'épilepsie attention
aujourd'hui c'est génial aussi à pierre
arditi ah ben quand même pierre arditi
caire de césar un molière un 7 d'or
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
officier de l'ordre national du mérite
bravo bon par contre il vous reste que 3
points sur votre permis donc ça sert à
rien se la péter non plus
la toile de génial avec clair c'est
qu'il n'a pas bougé physiquement c'est
vrai on a toujours connu vieux
d'ailleurs pour tous ceux qui pensent
que vous avez jamais été je ne vous
avais pas une peinture de vous a dû
lui si ma mission comme toutes les
semaines poser les questions trop con
que thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser alors à rien de vous est belle
drôle et en plus vous faites de la boxe
thaï vous savez que pour joey starr vous
êtes la femme idéale
chris marquès c'est vrai que si on vous
retire votre bananes vous est le sosie
de patrick timsit y paraît et dans un
article pierre g découvrir que votre
femme evelyne bouix va au cinéma six
fois par semaine à 10 euros la place
acheter un cinéma franchement ça ira
beaucoup plus avertis merci charleville
à notre stagiaire on retrouve ici la
semaine prochaine d'autres calmes et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu